[Music]
the artifacts speak louder than words
the way that we've preserved them it's
not what we said is what we did and
they'll speak very loudly for
generations and generations to
come my name is barry clifford and i'm
an explorer
[Music]
barry clifford has dedicated his life to
finding and preserving shipwrecked
treasure head towards the east chris
all right standby
his team is responsible for discovering
the wida one of the largest pirate
shipwrecks in the world valued at over
400 million dollars
the widow was a slave ship captured by
pirates and it wrecked off of wellfleet
massachusetts in april of 1717.
i've been diving on it since 1982. i
bought a boat and spent the next couple
of years looking for the ship and then
in 1984 we found the first artifacts and
then we found the ship's bell
and the ship's bell said the wida galley
1716.
everything is buried at least 15 to 30
feet under the sand so we have to dig
holes sometimes 30 feet deep to get down
to artifact layer you know you need
precise positioning equipment precise
anchoring techniques and a way to dig
very gently so you don't destroy or
disturb the artifacts there's some big
chunks of gold here chris wow look at
all the gold i got i had no idea how
much stuff we would find you're talking
about hundreds of thousands of artifacts
you know we have years and years and
years of work to conserve
everything that we've brought up that's
a spout that might have been used from a
rum keg unlike your typical treasure
hunter barry has never sold any of the
artifacts he's found choosing to put
them on display for the public to see
i made a promise to myself early on that
i was never going to sell the treasure
that we would keep it all together and
my crew and my family and people who've
worked with me over the years have all
felt the same way about preserving this
for our cultural heritage take your time
no rush i'd be lying if i said it wasn't
fun you're not going to believe where
that is chris i still get just as
excited about finding something as i did
35 years ago
[Music]
you